and a life in politics seemed
predestined for John F Kennedy jr. of
course he was also what America's was
famous bachelors before Carolyn Bessette
stole his heart yesterday we told you
about a big new documentary coming to
Spike TV and last night we were
exclusively with the filmmakers as they
shared new scenes with us and their
memories of the couple who wants to find
the new Camelot
she was quirky she was a bohemian maybe
a bit gypsy and and John's a free spirit
would she marry John in 1996 Carolyn
Bessette became an instant celebrity and
fashion icon how would you describe John
and Carolyn's relationship what were
they like as a couple they were very
playful they were romantic they were
they were buddies they were friends they
gossip together and they they had funny
inside joke birdie et saw just how
playful they could be rarely speaking to
the media she joked with us about
mingling with good-looking men at a
charity dinner I think it's sort of
fabulous I hope they're all sitting with
me the new Spike TV documentary I am JFK
jr. uncovers many stories about John's
life including how this first iconic
cover of his magazine George came about
for me it wasn't meeting a little boy
saluting the casket I think for my
mother it would have been that for me it
was like him he's like a hot New York
bachelor turns out it wasn't really
John's idea John of course came up with
well it should be somebody beautiful and
it should be and Carolyn said it should
be spending Crawford she is Americana
you know his tentacles of love is it
reaches out from the grape fill here now
in the film you're gonna learn this
incredible moment where John really kind
of steps out into the media and visits
Mike in prison and then comes forward to
the media to say hey let's give this guy
a break
which is a really interesting story
around John that this is something he
did on a regular basis John Carolyn and
her sister Lauren Bessette perished in
that plane crash on July 16th 1999
John's longtime friend Brian Steele had
a vision for the Kennedys
if their aircraft had not gone down off
the coast of Martha's Vineyard if John
and Carolyn were alive today what do you
think they would be doing he would have
run for president the country would love
him
and then obviously Carolyn would be in
theory the first lady you know he loved
children I think he would have been a
fantastic father so I mean you know I
think there would have been little
Kennedy's running around amazing to
think what would have been yeah could
you imagine now Camelot is not really
gone sister caroline is ambassador to
japan and her son john Schlossberg looks
just like his uncle john jr. and he's in
yell grad and I might say that he said
that he'd like to pursue politics
gonna be in today see if that happens